robert spencer putin is using muslim
jihadis from his own territories as his
hammer in ukraine how did this come
about and what does it mean for putin
and russia going forward
putin has
allowed ramzan khadirov the chechen
leader to have essentially a free hand
there
and so
khadirov owed him a favor
and had to collect and and so he had to
deliver and the russian imams have been
obliging in issuing a fatwa saying that
it was a legitimate conflict for muslims
to get involved in and uh the mufti of
chechnya even said it was a jihad
that all chechens should
at least support
the russian effort in ukraine meanwhile
the ukrainians have their own
muslim forces that are fighting for them
because obviously it's not a muslim
versus non-muslim conflict and
if it goes on and expands however the
only beneficiary might be
the islamic world